finally the sequel to one of the
quintessential 90s horror films but
before we talk about it i want to thank
the sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by the ridge wallet the
ridge is a new sleek modern take on the
wallet that's there to replace your old
bulky wallet it's sleek and compact in
design but also very fulfilling in
execution it holds 12 cards inside cash
on the back more than enough room to
hold any and all cards and content i
have any use for especially after i was
like i haven't used that since the obama
years i don't even know what that is is
that a depleted gift card i use that to
scrape frost off my windshield it has
over 30 colors and styles including
carbon fiber and burnt titanium that
quality means lifetime warranty and you
can try the ridge wallet for 45 days if
you don't like it return it full refund
so click the link below go to ridge.com
john's use promo code john save yourself
10 off your ridge wallet and thank you
once again to ridgewallet for sponsoring
this video i do appreciate it all right
now here we go all right so don't say
his name
just saying
[Music]
so candyman is a sequel to the 1992
movie candyman well damn that's twice i
only say that because there's a mirror
in my camera yeah all you youtubers out
there reviewing this movie odds are
there's a mirror in your camera too so i
guess we're all equally [ __ ] but it
looks like candyman's doing what a lot
of movies horror in particular is doing
now just like yeah there was that one
movie that was perfect and it crushed it
and then a bunch of sequels that oh
they didn't live up so now all these
decades later this is the true sequel to
the originals this is
all you need usually having the same
title is the original just to confuse
people so candyman stars yaya abdulmatin
ii he plays a struggling artist who gets
wrapped up into the candyman lore and
starts going down that rabbit hole and
candyman starts coming back and killings
happened and candyman the cast i thought
did a great job any of the shortcomings
in the script and there are quite a few
the cast does their best to make it work
it's not on them that yaya abdulmatin
martin ii was great as the lead tiona
paris who played monica rambo and won
division she's in this movie i thought
she was really good and a character that
really stands out as the comic relief
character but not overly comic relief
uses sarcasm to make light of a
situation but also knows when it's just
time to get the [ __ ] out nathan stewart
jared he's a standout in this movie what
i liked about this movie from the get-go
i was like it's beautiful it visually is
amazing i thought director nia decosta
did a great job at making a visually
compelling movie here whether it's the
opening credits or any scenes with
mirrors mirrors being a huge part of
this movie anytime there was a mirror i
caught myself looking in the mirror
looking for candyman looking back or
creeping in the background or something
sometimes he was there sometimes he
wasn't and any of the candyman killings
happening i thought they used mirrors
really well where candyman is invisible
but he's killing people but anytime it's
in front of a mirror in the reflection
you do see candy man i thought that was
really cool and it took me back to
nightmare on elm street where if
someone's getting killed by freddy
krueger in the dream you see it
happening but in the real world it's
like there's an invisible wraith and
this girl is not why is she on the
ceiling and they use that last point
about the mirrors and the killings to
kind of segue into what didn't work so
much for me and that's the fact that the
original candyman i can't help but
compare this movie to the original candy
man because i feel like this movie tried
to do what the original candyman did but
the original candyman movie just did it
better i like the fact that in this
movie visually and in terms of tone it
looks like they attempted to bring the
same tone from the original candyman
movie here on screen again in 2021
that's the fact that it's not a cliched
slasher flick blood fest it's actually a
compelling investigative character movie
only thing is the original candyman puts
the word compelling into that
description this movie is kind of a slow
crawl slow grind that's just not as
interesting to me because it's all about
nuance it's about execution you know
virginia madsen's character in the
original candyman the 1992 candy man
she's going down this rabbit hole she
says the name five times in the mirror
and then she starts passing out and when
she wakes up people are dead is candyman
killing people is she just blacking out
and killing people herself you don't
know it's a cool thing to think about
it's interesting to peel back those
layers while you're watching the movie
peel back more layers after you're done
watching the movie you're laying in bed
like well i can't sleep so let me just
unravel this movie in my head this movie
does none of that from the first
candyman killing i'm like oh yeah it's
invisible candyman killing people and
you see him in the reflection
the end of mystery as cool as the mirror
effects of invisible candyman killing
people but you can see his reflection in
the mirror was i was like oh well no
mystery then it's just kind of
that's what's happening also with social
commentary this movie seems so concerned
about having its social commentary but
you can't have anyone miss it so it's
gonna have zero subtlety whatsoever
social commentary in a movie is not a
bad thing many movies have done it and
stuck the landing the original candyman
being one of them but i felt the
original candyman did it in a way where
it was cleverly woven into the plot i
mean [ __ ] you could write a thesis about
what makes effective social commentary
in a film
but if you want to boil it down to a
sentence because you know why not it's
fun to do i would say it wouldn't be
inaccurate to say that effective social
commentary in a movie has to do with the
subtlety or brevity
of the illustration
versus how hard it hits this is one of
the ways i feel the original candyman
absolutely excel virginia madsen's
character talks about how her overpriced
apartments and the apartments in cabrini
green have the same layout because they
were the same apartments then they
remind you of that fact by location you
see her apartment and the apartments in
cabrini green maybe you notice it the
first time you watch the movie maybe
it's the second or third time but you
will eventually be like oh wow those are
the same layout look at that and it
sticks with you a lot more when you let
the audience get there on their own it's
like inception not the movie the concept
this new candyman movie would just
rather tell you some things like oh yeah
gentrification happened in cabrini green
moving on i guess that's a big problem i
had with this movie in a world where a
picture is worth a thousand words this
candyman movie would rather use a
thousand words to paint a picture than
show you and when it does want to show
you stuff it shows you the wrong stuff
it shows you too much and then ruins the
nuance the point is in both situations
it lacks nuance and it's not just the
script and the film lacking nuance it's
also character development there were
moments in this movie where it was like
huh we need to have a backstory or a
past so we'll show a flashback of some
sort like there's this one scene where
this character gets a childhood
flashback that's like oh that's a
tragedy that happened with her father
also
did you just kind of not have that and
then at a point like hey she needs a
childhood flashback so you have this one
flashback and then that's that yeah the
third act of this movie happens and it's
like they were like hey here's a slow
crawl movie about investigating candyman
and candyman killing people who say his
name in the mirror okay hey it's the
last act so let's get crazy they just
throw some [ __ ] at the wall to see if it
sticks and i was like
alright i guess
well it's more horror movie-ish kind of
conflicts and tone with the rest of the
movie and kind of feels like the kind of
candyman sequel that has come out before
where it just kind of feels like oh it's
that horror movie sequel that doesn't
live up to the original but in the end
this movie was lacking a huge part of
the soul that was candyman and that is
well
candyman for me what made candyman the
character cool wasn't that he killed
people it's when he showed up that
booming voice you know helen i can't
even do it i'm pretty good with voices
can't do that one tony todd's voice as
candy man she's one of a kind but there
was a captivating charisma to the
character when he showed up he was all
you saw and this movie doesn't have any
of that candyman shows up to kill people
and he's invisible but you see him in
the mirror which again cool effect but
they do a thing that's
closely tied into their social message
it is they went all in and if it speaks
to you you're gonna be like i dug the
movie and if it doesn't you're gonna be
like this does not feel like candy man
and for me it just it fell flat maybe
this movie would be a better time if i
were drunk yeah and it's not even a
party i'm just sad all right so candyman
either the new one or the original
either case have you seen them what did
you think about them whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]